good morning Todd if I asked you to sum
up the Rams season this past season how
would you sum it up like a nightmare man
what did you what did you expect um you
know I you know a lot more man
honestly expected at least 10 where
season and you know we started out three
and one you know like we was we have
some good momentum and then you know all
the wheels fell off we just can get it
back back together how depressed were
you you know I hate losing and you know
it's a terrible feeling it doesn't you
know just get worse and worse you know
every loss later on I just tried to stay
positive throughout the season and you
don't even know you know I wasn't gonna
have a good game week two week three you
know just trying to make sure that I was
you know just stay prepared you know
each weekend make sure we we just come
with the market we could still win and
try not to give up what's that feeling
like when you're staring across the line
of scrimmage you know you're getting the
football and the defense knows you're
getting the football my teammates it
don't matter they know we're running a
bar at the end of the day you know yes
um we don't want to want to not eat that
linebacker yet keep it yeah so you got a
man up and that's all football is about
you know it's trying got across you
morning ABC can you act like you're not
getting the football even though you're
getting the problem don't work take me
back to week 13 you lose at New England
what do you remember about the Patriots
they were just you know they're just
very discipline I'm discussing on
defense you know they were very sound
had great players no one playing outside
that gets you know hard hard to trick
trick the linebackers you know they
think you're going one way and it
bounced out so you know that was a great
defense for shorten and then obviously
watching Boston those guys off it so I'm
looking and Tom you know and then
holding those guys they play pretty well
great and then the following week you
come home and you get blown out by the
Falcons and the Falcons talked about
that that may have turned around their
season what do you remember about week
14 to the Patriots and we only score one
touchdown and we play against the
Falcons and maybe before you know first
play the game we fumbled the ball
it was like a nightmare man it was we
wasn't putting points on the board you
know offensive ly and you know we knew
that at the office that we needed to
step up you know to help the defense out
you know we just didn't we just wanted
Clinton
he's Todd Gurley the Rams running back
joining us Dan Patrick show you got a 30
31 year-old head coach in Sean McVeigh
tell me what having a young head coach
how does how is that something positive
I don't know you know I have the great
planning you know I'm excited to meet
him just to see the things he did over
there at Washington you know Matt Jones
and Rob Kelly all those guys Jordan Reed
so he did a great job and I'm excited
you know the work with him they sure who
has better hair in your head coach or
your quarterback probably build my
quarterback
it's a tough question though because you
want to kiss up to the head coach a
little bit but you want to be nice to
your quarterback as well
a lot of people say coachman pay look
like winch they say we got golf and
weighs down so so Shawn looks like
Carson wins a little bit oh is that a
good thing you're ready for the Chargers
to share the building is this it is this
a rivalry yeah you you want to wake up
we're not in the same division so but I
mean we wanted to wait you do that way
from the gate we got away well you can
talk trash you could say something here
that you know Melvin Gordon is overrated
or something like that or Philip Rivers
isn't any good or me stir it up a little
bit Todd come on does anything ever
happen in the pile like that we should
be aware of
now just because we'll never get that
experience of running the football and
then you get in there like like put us
in the pile there with you Todd man the
worst feeling being in the Polish we got
eight guys on top it's a lot going on
though I can tell you that and guys that
right then don't want to get up so you
got a but are they grabbing because they
want you to free up the football so they
can come out I mean is that what goes on
oh yeah you get that what a most part
you know everybody plays cleaning you
know I'm really clean I can't say I
played against a dirty player yet I know
that you're doing stuff with Gillette do
you want to give us the plug for
Gillette
oh yes I'm here with your left teaming
up with those guys and here with
Gillette kind of group clear gel it goes
going clear no white marks all this
potential keeps you dry and cool and
honest till when your adrenaline is high
you got to put on Gillette clinical
clear gel
excuse me dry cools and for the Super
Bowl to let clinical clear gel is
teaming up with your lips so it's in the
stress free tickets to the Super Bowl
travelers free car hotel check that out
on Twitter for more details and tomorrow
you were deodorant before you play yeah
all the time
I'll be out there feeling like like a
lineman to somebody
do you wear Cologne before again hey
good luck with this more importantly
good luck with next season and hopefully
they open some holes for you Todd the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]